attention aller plus loin tout de suite
avec notre invité du jour c'est vous
Jean-Paul Palomeros bonjour vous êtes
ancien chef d'état-major de l'armée de
l'air ancien commandant suprême allié de
la transformation de de l'auto merci
d'être à nos côtés pour tenter de nous
éclairer d'abord d'abord sur cette
livraison de renfort en matériel
l'arrivée de ces charabraham son envie
de dire enfin c'est une bonne nouvelle
selon vous
c'est forcément une bonne nouvelle qu'il
faut quand même tempérer d'abord vous
venez de le dire c'est tardif on en
parle depuis des mois et puis deuxième
élément sans faire la fine bouche c'est
quand même la première version des chars
Brahms
qui sont moins bien protégés mais enfin
et ils arrivent au nombre limité une
trentaine donc je crois que l'enjeu là
c'est pour Monsieur zenenski c'est de
faire en sorte que cette livraison soit
la première d'une d'une véritable
livraison en masse enfin de quelques
dizaines voire centaines d'abrahams qui
changerait profondément les choses mais
bon pour l'instant il faut s'en
satisfaire et toute la question de
savoir si les Ukrainiens vont s'en
servir directement aujourd'hui sur le
front le char Abraham ça se limite il
est très consommateur en énergie il est
assez lourd et il a parfois des
problèmes techniques donc il faut il
faut tourner ça en compte également pour
dans son emploi
je crois que nous en dire un peu plus on
parle beaucoup ces dernières heures
depuis publication par la presse
américaine de la livraison éventuelle de
missiles longues portées les fameux atcm
là aussi il va falloir voir de quoi de
quoi il est question
alors sur le charabraham c'est comme je
le dis à l'instant c'est vraiment la
première version celle qui date de 180
de 1980 il y a eu de nombreuses
évolutions depuis le char qui pèse dans
les 40 et quelques tonnes celui-là
aujourd'hui les derniers sharpes 60 et
quelques tonnes donc ils sont mieux
protégés c'est des chars qui qui tirent
malgré tout les fameux obus à uranium
appauvri donc ils sont capables de
percer des blindages très épais ça c'est
un côté très positif sur le deuxième
point c'est à dire les missiles les
attaquants les missiles de longue portée
même de très longues portées promis par
les Américains ça ça a été un sujet on
s'en souvient de des je dirais de
désaccord entre monsieur zen ski et les
Américains les Américains ne voulant pas
livrer ses armes à grande portée bon
maintenant il semble qu'il se décide
mais il faudrait qu'il fasse vite la
Maison Blanche jusque là c'était
toujours hors de question de de livrer à
Kiev ce genre de missile et là c'est la
presse américaine qui semble dire à la
Maison Blanche est en train de dire oui
alors
il faudra constater l'arrivée de ces
missiles leur nombre
il était donc au fur et à mesure entre
guillemets de l'escalade et l'intensité
cette guerre on a vu des livraisons de
matériel de plus en plus sophistiqués de
plus en plus pointues et donc qui sont
vraiment au cœur de la défense de chacun
des pays finalement qui les livres à
l'Ukraine et on peut comprendre une
certaine réticence sur ce type
d'armement qui sont vraiment des
armements de comme on l'a fait
d'ailleurs avec le missiles le croisière
aéroportée que ce soit les Anglais ou
les Français ça serait un petit peu
l'équivalent si on voulait faire la
comparaison pour que les gens
comprennent bien de
quoi des missiles avec
100 km selon là aussi le modèle qui est
effectivement livré si cette information
s'avérait être confirmée dans les heures
qui viennent les jours qui arrivent ça
voudrait dire quoi qu'on est en train de
franchir une ligne rouge posée par par
Moscou et Vladimir Poutine
la ligne rouge c'est plutôt les alliés
qui l'ont posé en faisant parler plus
leurs bons sens que la menace de la
Russie ce sont des pour éviter tout
ambiguïté on ne souhaite pas que les
Ukrainiens ne veut pas que les
Ukrainiens puissent utiliser les
armements occidentaux pour les frapper
au cœur de la Russie c'est un des
paramètres à prendre en compte en
revanche pour aller frapper en Ukraine
ce qu'on voit tous les jours avec
d'autres armements et dans le bon basse
évidemment à partir de position reculée
ça c'est intéressant aussi c'est à dire
avec des armements de cette nature vous
avez pas besoin d'être en ligne de front
c'est pas comme l'artillerie vous pouvez
tirer ça de différents
emplacements un peu comme les missiles
aéroportés qui font mouche en Crimée en
ce moment qui soit britannique ou
français est-ce que vous estimez vous
l'experts que vous êtes aujourd'hui
qu'on pourrait bientôt se trouver un
tournant de la guerre plusieurs succès
de l'armée ukrainienne sur le champ de
bataille nous sont nous sont rapportés
ces effectivement difficiles
d'y voir clair quel est votre avis à
vous
non je crois qu'il s'agit d'une des
énième phases je dirais de cette guerre
et l'offensive ukrainienne qui doit se
faire dans des conditions très
contraignantes parce que monsieur
zenenski veut limiter les pertes
humaines c'est le vrai sujet ça reste le
vrai sujet les effectifs les hommes les
femmes on voit les difficultés qu'il
peut y avoir à mobiliser maintenant les
jeunes Ukrainiens faut voir le turnover
après la rotation des troupes est très
très lente et très faible chez les
Ukrainiens donc il y a pas de
régénération donc
ça c'est un élément conséquent il y a
quand même une dépénétrations ça c'est
une bonne chose puisque ça peut
permettre de déstabiliser en tout cas
une partie du front et surtout sur cet
axe qui est recherché par les Ukrainiens
il faut voir jusqu'où ça va aller mais
il faut pas s'attendre à des résultats
spectaculaires on n'est pas un tournant
à la limite les frappes en Crimée elle
montre
j'allais vous poser la question sur la
Crimée effectivement qui a un point de
un point de tension dont on parle
beaucoup en ce moment il y a eu cette
annonce hier par Kiev la mort du
commandant de la flotte russe en mer
Noire donc donner pour mort par les
Ukrainiens ce que conteste les Russes
photos à la pluie ce monsieur est apparu
participant à une visioconférence
aujourd'hui là aussi difficile
de d'y voir clair
ce qui est ce qui n'est pas contesté
c'est que les Ukrainiens ont frappé
l'état-major de la de la flotte de la
mer Noire russe est-ce que l'amiral ou
non est mort dans dans cette attaque les
jours à venir nous le diront mais
il est évident que la campagne de frappe
à longue distance menée par les
Ukrainiens en crimés démontrent bien
leur volonté de frapper cet endroit
stratégique et de mettre la pression sur
sur les Russes qui sont imprimées tout
en s'attaquant aux objectifs militaires
et ça c'est pas facile de garder la
précision et grâce aux armements
occidentaux c'est
ce que vous pouvez tout l'enjeu de
frapper et de détruire ces navires qui
visiblement ne peuvent pas être
remplacés
depuis le début il y a effectivement
cette contrainte qui pèse
essentiellement sur les Russes dans la
mesure où les Turcs sont les gardiens
depuis les années 30 des détroits du
Bosphore et des Dardanelles donc et
auront interdit le passage de bâtiments
armés et donc les Russes ne peuvent pas
reconstituer leur flotte en mer Noire on
se souvient que les Ukrainiens avaient
réussi à m'exploit en coulant la moscla
qui était le bâtiment amiral
ukrainien pratiquement au début de la
guerre et là il est clair qu'ils vont
harceler en permanence cette flotte ils
ont aussi ils ont ils ont détruit
d'autres bâtiments également et là la
souveraineté je dirais la Russie ou la
main mise de la Russie sur la mer Noire
et contesté ce qui est une bonne chose
parce que ça permet aux Ukrainiens de
commencer à pouvoir s'en servir avec les
limites que les frappes russes touchent
toujours malgré tout on vient de
l'entendre de votre correspondant les
ports du Danube et là effectivement on
se rapproche de la Roumanie ça ça peut
être un enjeu ça peut poser les
problèmes comme ça avait été le cas en
août dernier d'ailleurs c'est des fêtes
en mer Noire ou en tout cas c'est ces
tensions qui qui se renforce peuvent
expliquer cette campagne
de tir de drones toujours aussi massive
sur l'Ukraine il faut y avoir une
réponse oui bien sûr et c'est une
réponse aussi au fait que les Ukrainiens
veulent s'affranchir de l'accord qui
existait sur l'exportation de grains et
pour son affranchir ben ils utilisent la
bordure de la mer Noire leurs eaux
territoriales et ils passent directement
Roumanie et ça explique parfaitement les
dernières frappes qui ont touché ce port
qui est juste frontalié avec la Roumanie
ou passe un certain volume de grains par
évidemment c'est pas toute la production
ukrainienne bien loin de là mais enfin
c'est une manière pour les Ukrainiens de
contourner un peu cette ce manque
d'accord avec les Russes sur la
poursuite de l'export du gras qui est
vital pour les Ukrainiens du du tout du
goût de Moscou merci beaucoup Jean-Paul
palomaros merci d'avoir été notre invité